hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video it is Thursday it is deaf stream
recap date and we have tons of info
today talking about the new executions
what they look like new gear a new map
the two new reworks coming and then
stuff coming in season six as well as
but the title is and then what to
prepare for the day that we get it so as
always guys like the video if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the information the leaks the patch
notes the balance changes the seasonal
events everything informational side a
for honor
like I said subscribe if you're new and
let's get started so two really quick
things there's going to be time stands
at the bottom in the description of the
exact times that you want to click to
because there's going to be lots of
information and some of you might
already know some of the things so for
example if you know what the reworks are
but you have not seen the new map you
can just click on the timestamps you can
be taken directly to that so I don't
waste any of your time and as well I'm
going to be having a live stream on this
Saturday roughly around 1:00 to 2:00 est
so come by this Saturday look around for
that come by to chill out have some fun
with everybody in the stream I'd love to
see you guys there
and now let's finally get in the news
for today so first up season six is
gonna be called heroes March and it
starts May 17th the free weekend is also
available so if you have any friends
that are older knew that ones who
experienced the game again definitely
tell them about it in the game and the
season pass are also on sale so if you
haven't gotten the season passed tell
them about that or if they haven't
obviously gotten the games in third free
weekend player tell them about that as
well thing at a discounted price they
also mentioned that new heroes are
coming this year but there is no
confirmed date so it could be the meet
the next season maybe season 7 or season
8 we have no clue yet but there are new
heroes coming this year there also be a
new seasonal event this season similar
to frost one festival test your mettle
in feast of the Otherworld like I said
will be coming this season as well which
is very exciting there is no like I said
confirmed date but it should be here
this season and they will be having full
patch notes that will come with more
info on the reworked details and other
things they didn't mention in this
stream on the next stream next week
Thursday so deftly stick around on the
channel for that type of news as well
next up we're gonna be talking about the
reworks and there are two characters
that are going to be reworked for season
six and that is going to be peacekeeper
and Orochi sadly there is no valkyrie i
have no clue why they didn't do Valcke
maybe they're [ __ ] with us and
they're actually going to put her in it
some other points they didn't mention it
but from what I got from the stream
is know going there's going to be no
Valkyrie work as of yet but first up is
peacekeeper and the reason she was
reworked is that she's very
one-dimensional and not many PK players
utilize her full kit and that she had
too high overall damage but first up is
dagger cancel and it will now come on
the top guard stance instead of the same
stance of the inner of the original
heavy so it used to be the heavy attack
would go on the right and then the kit
the dagger cancer would also go on the
right guard stand so even if they tried
to block the heavy and obviously you
feint it if they would automatically
block the bleed light so it'd make them
move pretty useless next up is their
heavy finisher you can now guard break
faint or dodge faint her heavy finisher
which if you don't know what a heavy
finisher is it is the last heavy in the
chain which obviously has a heavy in it
so any combo with a heavy in the last
portion of the move you can now guard
break faint or dodge fainted which will
allow for better mix ups and as well you
can also stack her bleed before all you
would have to do is just do a few bits
of bleed damage then it wouldn't stack
so basically doing any more bleed would
be useless now you can stack the bleed
as long as you can as you can see in the
clips of gameplay shown on screen but
sadly not everything is too good she
does get a few bit of nerves her zone
attack is now 15 damage on the first hit
instead of 20 people would always use
the zone attack and just faint the
second hit so it's incredibly hard to
block or parry not even some of the pros
a foreigner can even block or parry the
move so it is a very fast attack so now
like I said the zone attack is not gonna
do 15 damage on the first hit instead of
20 her light attack openers now do 13
damage instead of 17 her heavy openers
now do 20 damage instead of 33 heavy
finishers now do 25 instead of 30 and -
forward heavy now does 15 instead of 20
damage so a little bit of a decrease on
her heavy openers and finishes as well
as some of her light attacks as well
next up is Orochi and the reason they
did this is because of the limited
options he had in his kit and especially
after the recent parry changes they
basically kind of [ __ ] them over a
little bit so the bait and obviously the
basic approach it would just do top
lights guard break in his own and kind
of mix that in so there really wasn't
much variety first changes storm rush
and now you can do storm rush from any
direction and the top one is undoubtable
so if they try to draw it out of the top
one if they cannot and they will
automatically get hit you can
technically still direct cancel into a
guard break but it is a little bit
slower and it can be used if the chain
attacks as seen on screen right now for
Riptide strike the new button input' is
a back dodge light attack
and it's faster I can now also be in
combos these side lights are 500ms
instead of 600 m/s the second lights are
400 from 500 m/s and the light finishers
are 400 m/s from the top and 500
milliseconds from the side if the chain
is heavy light heavy the obviously that
is the second light and second lights do
400 m/s so that will basically be the
same to put that into perspective though
berserkers light attacks current patch
also do 400 m/s so watch out these moves
will be incredibly fast now obviously
since is attached a little bit faster
they're going to be a lot less damage
his light opener is 15 damage instead of
17 his second light is 12 damage instead
of 15 and his heavy finishers now do 35
damage as opposed to 38 now that we're
done with the rework so let's move on to
the new map so the new map is called
beachhead and it's a samurai map and it
can be played in Dominion skirmish
elimination brawl and duel this map is
heavily inspired by the campaign map
where the Vikings rated the samurai
fortress where you played as the Raider
and assassinate the Ken's a leader which
is why the map and ships look very close
to it and it's a smaller map so it's a
lot more fast paced so be paired to be
in fights almost every single second of
the game capture point a has a ton of
shields around the wall which look
really nice and decorative when these
were according to the devs where the
samurai would repair their equipment
after a long siege or fight and capture
point C is on the opposite of a there
really isn't much special to it but they
are overlooking point B for potential
plunging attacks as you can see you can
also look across from either objective
to c4 teammates need help at capturing
that specific objective personally to me
I like small and fast-paced Maps so this
will be a really cool addition to the
game and I can't wait to hop in once
this releases and place them to mini
matches on this next up and probably the
second favorite thing that they showed
during the stream was the gear and they
added this new feature called color
swatch some of the weapons that have
colors in blue and red can change colors
depending on your outfit so if you
happen to have a green color the color
will show up green and obviously it's
for neutral attackers defenders all the
type of good stuff now it's not on every
single weapon it's only on a few of them
because they wanted to test this out but
if it gets a very positive response from
the community they will gladly add it
into every weapon as well as in future
seasons so I managed to grab all the
weapons from the stream I don't know if
these are the only sets of weapons or
for getting multiple other sets but in
the first batch of images that were from
the stream they are warden Centurion PK
and conquer the second group is law
bringer gladiator Kensi and Nobu she the
third group is shougo ki Orochi shinobi
and ara Musha the fourth group is Raider
Berserker warlord and Highlander and
then the last two are Valken shaman I
may have gotten the Orochi Ken say
Sora's mixed up because obviously it
depends on how big they are in terms of
length the Orochi has a smaller sword in
catch a Ken say has a very big sword but
I couldn't see the length of their
swords from the stream since they didn't
go down that far but I know for a fact
everything other than those two are 100%
correct next up is the inventory fix and
they have this new thing called visual
collection obviously one of the reasons
that we had this is a lot of people are
getting these new weapons obviously with
the new gear coming a lot of people are
going to be getting these new types of
gear and weapons and they don't have
enough room for it so like I said they
added a new system called visual
collection and it's in the change look
tab on your armor every time you get a
new look it automatically comes in the
visual tab so you won't need to save
certain gear because of it because the
looks automatically save in the change
look tab if any of you have played
Diablo it's similar to the
transmogrification type system where it
doesn't matter if you have the weapon or
anything as long as you have that type
of skin it stays forever and the same
applies here even if you have it
destroyed it stays in the change look
tab and even if you loot something from
an event like the frost one festival
test or metal or you get it at a lower
tier so let's say I get it at level one
but now I'm a rep ten gladiator and I
still want to use that at that type of
armor set then you can still use it
regardless of your rank so like I said
no matter what circumstances you can
equip any type of gear regardless if the
Alpha is destroyed a lower rarity or an
event weapon which is absolutely
incredible and obviously it's just based
off looks so you can keep weapons or you
can keep type of armor that have these
stats and not have to worry about looks
crowding your inventory and as well they
added new rewards at rep 40 and rep 50
you're gonna be getting a ornaments
specific a trap 40 obviously for every
character it's going to be different and
to rep 50 outfits as well as a specific
outline you get once you hit run fifty
with one character which looks like this
on screen
there will be more info on this next
week as well as well as a change in the
refined gear tab so definitely stay
tuned next week like I said for more
info second to last thing on here is the
executions and probably my favorite part
of the entire dev stream these look
absolutely marvelous I will show the
video now and
we'll come back once that's over these
are going to be releasing on May 10th
and there is no talk about what the
steel count of what these executions are
or regardless I'll show them all to you
right now and we will be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so those were the executions guys let me
know what you guys what your favorite
one was in the comments below
I love shoe jockeys one I don't know why
they make gladiator always fight the
opponent again that's two that's two
executions where he's had two done that
wardens is cool every single one of
these is super well done so shout out to
the mocap team and the execution guys
and then to end this behemoth of a
[ __ ] length of a video we have
content of the week and that's the new
elite outfits now obviously the new
elite outfits compared to the executions
aren't that great but wings of death is
the outer for the night's carrion forest
for the Vikings and cranes garden for
the samurai they are cool but to me it's
not entirely worth it but it might be to
you so if you have some extra steel
definitely get those all you have to
chance and that is gonna be the end of
the video today guys thank you guys for
sticking through to the entire video you
guys are absolutely amazing like the
video if you did enjoy really does help
me out subscribe if you're new like I
said I cover the informational side of
foreigner that being patch notes updates
big changes that being like seasonal
events news coverage weekly on the dev
stream all the type of stuff patch notes
like I've said informational site a for
honor I like to cover so all your info
news come to me
my two most recent videos are gonna be
on screen if you guys haven't seen those
highly recommend you do with that guys
hope you have a great rest your day
thank you for watching the video and
peace out